كثيرون يعتبرون ما يحصل في اوكرانيا
امتدادا الانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي
ترك وراءه حدودا مشتعله واقليه الروسيه في
دول حديثه نشات عن التفكك وبحجه الاضطهاد
الديني او اللغوي تتدخل اله موسكو
لحمايتها كان هذا الحل في جوجل ثم في
اوكرانيا لكن غير بعيدا عن روسيا تعتبر
يوغوسلافيا قبل تفككها مثالا مصغرا اشترى
الاحداث الروسيه ولكن بصوره اكثر تعقيدا
[موسيقى]
ورغم النقاط المشتركه بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي ويوغوسلافيا الا ان تفكك الاخيره
كان اكثر تعقيدا صربيا عكس روسيا لم
تعتبرها الامم المتحده وريثه لغزلافيا
وهنا اصبحت الحدود حقول الغامقه
فقدت منطقه تلو الاخرى حتى جاء دور كسوفو
عام 2008 بلاد الدوله الحديثه كان عصيرا
وفرض تدخل النيتو لانهاء الحرب التي اتهمت
فيها بلغراد بالتطهير العرقي صربيا هذه
المره عكس الدول الخمس المستقله الاخرى لم
تعترف باستقلاليه تعتبرها امتدادها الحضري
والديني لكن الامر لا يقتصر على صربيا
وحدها كوسوفو بقيت تحت عهده الامم المتحده
وبحمايه قوات النيتو حتى عام 2012 وخلال
هذه الفتره حصدت كوسوفو اعتراف 99 دوله
نتاع عشره منها اوروبيه
الاعترافات لم تكن من اجل نيل عضويه الامم
المتحده بسبب اعتراض روسيا والصين دعم
طبيعي لحليف النادر في اوروبا لكن الحجه
هي اضطهاد الاقليه الصربيه في كوسوفو هذا
السبب هو اهم اسباب استقلال كسوف عن صربيا
لكن الامر انقلب الان وصربيا تتهم الالبان
وهم غالبيه سكان كوسوفو باقصاء الاقليه
الصربيه
كوسوفو البلد الذي يسكنه مليونان و200 الف
نسمه اغلبهم من اصل البني
94% لكن السته في المئه المتبقيه يشكلها
الكوسوفيون من اصول صربيا 160 الفا في
المجموعه يسكنون في شمال البلاد ويشكلون
الاغلبيه هناك
لم تكن حكومه كوسوفو يوما مستعده لسماع
الناس او فهم رغباتهم يحتاج الناس في
برشتينا الى فهم ان جميع الصرب في شمال
كوسوفو يعتبرون صربيا بلدهم وليس كوسوفو
وهذا امر طبيعي لكن حكومه بريشتينا ترفض
الاعتراف بهذا الواقع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات